the House Judiciary Committee voted
today to subpoena the full unredacted
molar report along with the evidence
cabinet in the investigation
despite its full release being against
DOJ rules that were approved by the
Democrats because they didn't want the
old law in place Oh
the investigative council member of the
Independent Counsel rule joining us now
congressman Devin Nunez former chair and
now the opposition majority minority
leader in the house Intel committee
Congressman Jim Jordan you know the
Independent Counsel rule let's see Jerry
Nadler was against the Ken Starr report
Jim if I remember correctly I'm just
trying to remember here they went after
your partner Devin Nunez pretty hard I
did because he went to the White House
now I see that the Cowardly shift was
offered four hours of airtime - won't
come on I want to know if they're the
ones that changed the rules and the
Attorney General doesn't he doesn't have
to release anything does he no he
doesn't but understand the situation
we're in John Ratcliffe said it best
today in committee the Intelligence
Committee Chair Adam Schiff wants the
Attorney General of the United States to
release classified information the
judiciary chair Jerry Nadler wants the
Attorney General of the United States to
release grand jury material that's where
we're at because they are so focused on
getting the president forget about the
law that they did they helped change
forget about the rule of law and how
things are supposed to happen they're
all about getting the President and that
is a sad state of affairs but that's
exactly where we're at all right let me
ask you congressman Nunez you have been
saying that you are you have criminal
referrals coming this week or next week
it I think if we ever want to prevent
this from happening again to any other
president the only way to make that
happen is one way hold those people
accountable accountable how many people
how soon how serious the referrals so
you're exactly right Shawn the American
people need to have confidence in the
FBI and the Department of Justice so we
are working on the referrals there
there's going to be many of them they're
going to probably at least be a dozen if
not two dozen individuals
Joules and as we continue to get more
information and build these and build
them out we want to make sure that
everything is finished before we before
we turn them in but I will tell you
you're exactly right there are people
who definitely lied and misled Congress
okay so if they don't go to prison we're
gonna have a two-tier justice department
justice system in this country and it's
not going to be good for the American
people I don't think it's got like a lot
of this been good for the American
people you know the Democrats were
fueling you for jeopardizing sources and
methods and you know what congressman
Nunez well the Attorney General said
he's not going to reveal sources and
methods Wow yeah oh don't forget that in
nowhere tinfoil hat conspiracy theorist
liar in Congress he says no I really got
the collusion this time don't we don't
forget whenever you wanted to when we
wanted to make sure that we got fusion
gps's bank records this was the Clinton
campaign arm that basically ran and got
dirt from Russians it was paid for by
the Clinton campaign the Democrats
throughout the house said oh you can't
do this
when we wanted to go out and say look we
think there's FISA abuse when we did our
memo that went out to the American
people that said look we're not going to
disclose sources and methods but the
American people need to know what
happened here
they opposed that so the the hypocrisy
here knows no bounds but with all that
said I think people should be very leery
of only receiving what I call the molar
dossier partisans wrote this document
what I'm interested in is not just to
receive the molar dossier I want all the
information that fed into this because
I'm sure just like in everything else
that we've dealt with over the last two
years there's going to probably be a lot
of fake innuendo in the Moller docile
you got to look for one line for a
sentence and the dist harpooner forever
even though very quickly without even
considering whether you can indict a
sitting president they said no does it
does you have to have intent for
obstruction has to be a crime for
obstruction it doesn't matter you know
well Donald Trump says this is a
witch-hunt
or he fired James Comey Comey said he
could do it for any reason or no reason
all right Doug Collins your colleague
freedom caucus member Jim he's been very
helpful in releasing these closed-door
testimonies but we're expecting a cast
of new information that we have all
talked about 302s gang of eight the
Phi's applications what else will we do
we want and when we get it and what will
we see well a couple of things Michael
Horowitz a report I think will be good
and that should be coming sometime in
the next few months but to Devon's point
your point if we want the truth of Jerry
Nadder wants the truth then let's let's
release the FISA application let's get
the 302 if Jerry Nadler wants the truth
calling Glenn Simpson bring him in an
open hearing put him under oath see if
he takes the fifth like he did in front
of our committee in a closed-door
deposition if we really if they really
want the truth bring in John Huber see
what he's been up to for ten months he's
supposed to be looking into this 5s
application and frankly if they really
want the truth and they don't want to
jeopardize releasing classified and
grand jury material bring in Bob Muller
wonder if we can ask him all the
questions we're on jury information is
illegal you right what exactly right but
I think we should just bring in Bob
Muller we can ask him all the questions
we want and and and not jeopardize that
at all and anything they want to ask the
guy who was the special counsel who they
said for 22 months was going to find
collusion and he did it it was not there
even though there were multiple
opportunities for Trump associates to
collude the fruit was dangling firm and
they didn't take it bring Bob Muller in
what we'll ask me I concluded it Devon
Nunez your committee concluded it the
bipartisan Senate committee said the
same now the Moller report whoever
believes it at this point is a tinfoil
hat psycho conspiracy theorists this is
insane
what they put the country through thank
you both